he was a martial artist actor teacher
and philosopher he is widely considered
to be one of the most influential
martial artists of all time he is often
credited with helping change the way
Asians were presented in American films
he's Bruce Lee and here his top ten
rules for success
you see actually I do not teach you no
karate because I do not believe in
Styles anymore I mean I do not believe
that there is such thing as like Chinese
way of fighting or the Japanese Way of
fighting or whatever way you're fighting
because I'm less human being have three
arms and four legs we will have a
different form of fighting but basically
we have only two hands and two feet so
Styles tends to a not only separate man
you know because they have their own
doctrines and then the doctrine became
the gospel chains you know that you
cannot change you know and but if you do
not have styles if you just say well
here here I am you know as as a human
being how can i express myself totally
and completely now that way you won't
create a style because style is a
crystallization you know I mean that way
it's a process of continuing growth when
I look around I always learn something
and that is to be always yourself and to
express yourself to have faith in
yourself do not go out and look for a
successful personality and duplicate him
now that seems to me that that is the
prevalent thing happening in Hong Kong
like they always copy mannerism but they
never start from the very root of his
being and that is how can I be mean a
good martial artist does not become
tense but ready not thinking yet not
dreaming ready for whatever may come
when the opponent expand like contract
when it contracts I expand and when
there is an opportunity I do not it did
hits all by itself often time people
come up and say hey troops are you
really that good
I said well if I tell you I'm good
probably you will stay on boasting if I
tell you I'm no good you know one line I
said empty your mind be formless
shapeless like water now you put water
into a cup it becomes the cup you put
water into a bottle it becomes the
bottle you're putting in a teapot it
becomes the teapot now water can flow or
it can crash be water my friend in case
you have missed the recent news she
could no of which I am the founding has
been elected and accepted into the black
belt Hall of Fame in America this must
the first time a recently developed form
of martial art is nationally accepted no
chicken though is not thousands or even
hundreds of years old
it started in a loud 1965 by a dedicated
and intensified man called Bruce Lee and
my martial art is something that no
serious martial artist can ignore I have
no fear of opponent in front of me but I
am very self sufficient that they do not
bother me and that should I fight should
I do anything I have made up my mind and
that's it baby
you better kill me before what was that
an exhibition we emotional content how
did it feel to you
I think bu it is like a finger pointing
away to the moon don't concentrate on
the finger or you will miss all that
heavenly glory well you know everyone
talks to me about Bruce Lee because
Bruce Lee and I were very good friends
and we trained together for like three
years before he left for Hong Kong to
pursue his movie career and I didn't
hear anything from Bruce for like two
years then out of the blue Bruce calls
me he says I've done two movies in Hong
Kong and they're really successful I
want to do a movie now with a fight
scene that everyone will remember and I
want to do the fight scene in the
Coliseum in Rome and I want you to be my
opponent at that time I held the world
title and kiddingly I say to Bruce I
said well who wins Bruce and he says I
win I'm the star of this movie and I
said oh I see you want to beat the world
champion he said no I don't I want to
kill the world champion
thank you guys for watching I made this
video because the B song asked me to so
if there's a famous entrepreneur you
want me to profile next leave it in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do
I'd also love to know which of Bruce
Lee's tips you find most relevant most
helpful most practical leave a comment
below and I'm curious to see how the
discussion goes thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon